here to present a special Academy Award
of Merit is critically acclaimed
director screenwriter and producer
Christopher Nolan thank you there are
alchemists who for over a hundred years
in various windowless rooms basements
what have you all across the world have
practiced a very special form of alchemy
that is turning silver and plastic into
dreams and not just any kind of dreams
but the kind of dream that you can
unspool from a reel and hold in your
hand hold up to the light and see frozen
magically and these dreams can be run
through a projector thrown onto a screen
where they will spark the imagination
and emotion of audiences as they have
all across the world for so long for so
many generations of filmmakers so I'm
very pleased to be here speaking on
behalf of this award to the men and
women who have practiced this very
special dark art the Academy's Board of
Governors and the Science and Technology
Awards Committee have chosen to
recognize all of the men and women all
of the companies involved in laboratory
work and in the processing of film the
technology that lies at the heart of
filmmaking and still represents the gold
standard of imaging technology this
award will be on display in the Sandburg
old theater until the Academy's new
museum is completed where it will be on
display as a permanent reminder to
future generations of the fine work of
all of these men and women this award is
in recognition of the first hundred
years of this fine work
I personally am very excited for the
next hundred years this work and
I'm I'm very pleased to be announcing
this special award thank you very much